hi just trying to find the lighting well
the perfect hotels hotel room lighting
you guys I'm gonna stop moving you
around I'm just gonna go set you
somewhere so I haven't given you guys a
little update in a while um as you know
I've been in Iceland freaking Iceland
how's this how's that lighting not good
no how'd you do what I tell you to do
camera oh what's a bad angle you never
want to shoot yourself from below cuz
you look like a whale
no now you can't even see me at all okay
I think we're settled so I should say hi
I'm actually in New York right now if
you're doing so much traveling lately
and that's nothing new or I always say
I'm gonna stop traveling and just take a
little break and make youtube videos
which I mean I still make videos when
I'm traveling but it's so hard because
the amount of stuff but I travel with
I'm gonna show you this picture of the
stuff that I took with me to Iceland it
was crazy
me and my sisters were playing the roles
of an entire film crew we were editing
we were shooting we had lighting we had
love's we had all kinds of microphones
and it's quite a process let me tell you
for anybody who thinks making YouTube
videos are easy and if you are making
YouTube videos and it's easy for you
please give me all of the tips because
I'd like to know takes a lot of time
actually I bought this bracelet
yesterday
it's a chakra bracelet I forget which
one I got I'll look it up later
so I'm in New York were announcing that
we're doing a second season of hard
wired so I'm pretty excited if you guys
missed the first season I'll put a link
in the description that you guys can
watch the first season I can't wait it's
been such a fun show to shoot a first
season was all about wearable technology
so like bits and brain implants that
this season we're gonna expand on not
just wearables we're gonna kind of do
everything so we're calling it hardwired
2.0 cuz well season 2 2.0 teki and riva
shooting 2 episodes this week we're
doing the announcement today so I can't
wait I'm so excited it's such a fun show
well now my braid fell out I would like
to talk about who's curling iron that I
bought yesterday I've been having to
curl my hair lately because it's so long
that like when I wear it straight it
just looks like I'm wearing a wig like
it looks like I have a wig I don't
we've this is my hair it's just long and
freakin long so let me get well just can
you guys hold on a second no I think the
the maid must have threw the box away
but I did take a picture so this curling
iron came with like this free headband
and they made it seem like this headband
was the most amazing headband in the
world it's kind of terrible I don't know
the box was so funny it just made me
laugh okay but maybe it's not that funny
but I laughed when I was purchasing it
and the only reason I bought it is
because there was no other curling iron
that I could purchase at this place and
the one that I had here was broken so I
love when people say the struggle is
real because most of the things that
people say but the struggle is real it's
not real like a freaking curling iron is
that what's the struggle there's no
struggle I'm thinking about doing an
advice segment because most of the
questions that I get from you guys is
like advice on something I might not
give the best advice in the world but I
have done a lot of things I've met a lot
of people I've been in a lot of
situations where I've learned a lot of
things and usually every bad situation
that I've been and I have come out of
that learning something and when people
ask me what does something in your life
that you wish that you could take back
and you can see man I really wish that
wouldn't have happened I the completely
honest answer to that is there's nothing
in my life that I would ever say I wish
that didn't happen because everything
that has happened I've learned something
learned a lot of things if you're going
through something right now
sucks it's gonna suck it'll probably
suck for a while may not seem like it
now but one day you're gonna realize the
thing that you learned from that
situation and be like huh yeah I'm glad
I know that now
but if you make the same mistake more
than once sometimes it takes people a
few more times to learn things that they
need to learn that's okay I said it
again oh for my flight home I'm trying
to figure out what the next book is that
I should read I've actually loved all of
your suggestions and probably reading
the divergent series was one of my
favorite suggestions that you guys have
suggested for me if I read I mean have
read to me I'm obsessed with audible
like honestly I don't know how I do not
discover this sooner everyone is always
like yeah
I read such-and-such book well guess
what now I can say I've read it too have
read to me you guys wanna get your free
otter look you can get one on
audible.com slash iJustine and you'll go
30-day free trial and all kinds of fun
stuff let me would you guys think I
should read and let me know what you've
read last I actually have to head to a
meeting right now I'm so sleepy jet lag
is the craziest thing being in Iceland I
was 7 hours ahead of my normal time and
then I went back to LA for a week so
just as I was getting adjusted to that
timezone now I'm in New York I don't
know about you guys but I need sleep the
thing about me is I can sleep anywhere I
can sleep anywhere like you I will go
outside right now in the middle of this
New York Street and I will freaking pass
out in the middle maybe maybe on the
sidewalk right in the concrete I could
just mmm goes right off I used to sleep
under desks in study hall in high school
all right I would even bring like a
little travel pillow with me and I would
just curl right up and I'd always wear a
jacket the day that I knew that I would
have a nice study hall so I could just
curl up underneath the desk people would
be doing work I would also have my
friends like sit in front of me so that
I can sleep and the teacher wouldn't
know I was there although he knew I was
there he's not stupid most these people
aren't stupid like teachers are not dumb
that's the thing that we never realized
when we were young how we thought we
were so freakin smart like you guys
right now in school you probably think
you're so smart well guess what no it's
not true
we're all stupid and these teachers know
exactly what they're doing they know
exactly what we were doing yeah okay
we're just gonna let you get away with
it but sometimes man when you do pull
one over on a teacher it's the best
feeling bobby pins a bobby pin could
never be found when you need it it's
like a unicorn where's the unicorns I
don't know I don't know I'm just
rambling because I actually really enjoy
just sitting here and spewing out words
at you guys hopefully you enjoy it too
thinking about some more fun videos to
make I do have a cooking video coming up
pancakes have a few more Iceland vlogs I
think those will be going on my second
channel I gotta go do some stuff now
here in the city hopefully I'll run into
some of you guys on the street if you
guys ever do see me out in the wild
please do say hi because it is
most thing to get to see you guys and
then I see your pictures on Twitter and
you tweet them to me and it's like we're
best friends it's like we're freakin
best friends ever see you later
let me know what book you guys end up
getting with audible.com slash Drive
justine hey looks great today can't wait
to curl my hair without weird freaking
curling hurt okay I'll see you